Margeaux Sanger Katz covers healthcare
for the New York Times and she joins us
now Margot good morning thanks for being
let's start with this whole idea of
repeal only is that a viable option and
what would it what would it do to the
insurance market it would be a very
messy situation the Congressional Budget
Office actually looked at this scenario
a couple of months ago and basically
what they found is that it would break
the insurance market so you would end up
with a situation in which 18 million
fewer Americans would have insurance
next year by the end of a decade if no
other changes would make 32 million more
Americans would be without insurance and
premiums would double so this is this is
an idea that is promised on the further
idea that they would be able to come up
with some kind of solution some kind of
replacement bill separately but it's an
awfully risky strategy because if all
they can do is vote out this repeal bill
then there are a lot of very negative
consequences that would flow from that
so let's talk about the option that is
presently on the table the Senate bill
the president famously said that he
thought the the House bill would quote
me and he wanted the Senate bill to have
more quote Hart does the Senate bill
have more heart it seems like the
elderly and the lower-income in America
are sort of the ones that get the
shortest end of the stick in this latest
iteration of the bill yeah I think the
Senate you know they've tried to go back
to the drawing board and write a
slightly different bill than the House
bill and I think they tried to address
some of these problems that low-income
and older people were really
disadvantaged under the house approach
but when the Congressional Budget Office
did its assessment they basically said
no it's really not that much better
you're still gonna have older people who
really are not going to be able to
afford their insurance and lower-income
people who may be able to buy insurance
but it's gonna be with such a high
deductible that it's not going to be
very useful to them so the you know
there was one big change that I think
was important which is the House bill
took out pre-existing conditions
protections in a really big way this
does it in a sort of more subtle way
which we could talk about but I think if
if President Trump was worried about
that about pre-existing conditions then
maybe he is satisfied that this bill is
a little bit less mean but in terms of
lots of people and particularly
vulnerable people who need health care
losing their insurance I think this bill
has some of the same effects as the
House version according to the
Congressional Budget Office the largest
savings in this bill comes from
reductions in Medicaid spending what
effectively did would that
I think it could have some pretty
substantial effect so the thing to
understand is that there's kind of two
parts of Medicaid there was the Medicaid
that existed before the Affordable Care
Act and then there was an expansion to
Medicaid that happened as part of the
bill so part of the Affordable Care Act
was that Medicaid went to a lot of low
income adults who didn't have children
who didn't have good health insurance
options before but the changes under
this bill would affect the entire
program so that includes children the
elderly disabled Americans and some very
poor parents of young children or
pregnant women and so you know the
assumption is that states will be able
to make up the difference or states
would be able to find more efficient
ways to provide care for those
populations but if you listen to the
states they say it's really not possible
that this really just amounts to a
budget cuts and with the total result
and cutbacks in care
you mentioned pre-existing conditions
let's talk about that what it what is
the measurable difference between the
two bills and what does it mean for
Americans that have pre-existing
conditions so what the Affordable Care
Act said is that if you want to buy
insurance you get to buy it at the same
price of anyone else regardless of
whether you have had an illness in your
past and the House bill said no insurers
should be allowed to sell insurance to
people who have a history of illness at
a higher price than people who have been
healthy so that's not part of this bill
this bill does not it's it still says
like Obamacare that everyone has to be
charged the same price but it allows
states to get rid of rules that set
minimum benefit standards so Obamacare
says if you want to sell health
insurance it has to include prescription
drug coverage it has to include hospital
care it has to include maternity
benefits and this bill would allow
states to say no no it doesn't have to
cover those things so you could imagine
that someone say who has cancer might be
able to buy a plan at a good price in a
state that gets rid of these rules but
that plan might not actually cover all
of the care that they need so it's not
as bad for people with pre-existing
conditions but it could be worse for
people who are sick okay an important
difference there yeah and we still have
no final legislation the other board no
more Grossinger cats thank you so much
for being with us this morning
thanks a lot